Joining us from Pennsylvania
Republican Senator Pat Toomey
Senator welcome back to Fox News
Sunday good morning Mike Thanks
for having me enhanced
unemployment benefits ran out
Saturday we could be facing
a government shutdown midnight
Monday night Senator you
disagree with some
of the provisions in this
massive funding package why
should the president sign it
well because you don't get
everything you want to even
if you're the President
of the United States we have
to legislative bodies
and Democrats control one
Republicans the other look if it
were just the free-standing
government funding bill I would
almost certainly be voting
against that but I think
the covid relief measures are
really really important and you
know in
my state as in many other states
we have governors who are
closing down businesses again
people are out of work certainly
through no fault of their own I
think we need the extended
unemployment benefits I think we
need another round of the pp
loans which are really grants
to small businesses to keep
their workforce part
of their business
and time's running out so I
understand the president would
like to send bigger checks
to everybody I think what he
ought to do is sign this bill.
And then make the case Congress
can pass another bill I
don't agree with $2,000 checks
to people who've had no lost
income whatsoever, which is
the vast majority of Americans
but the president is free
to make that case Democrats will
agree with that and see where it
ends up.
But we've got a bill right now
that his administration helped
negotiate I think we ought
to get that done your colleague,
Senator Lindsey Graham has
tweeted after spending some time
with President Donald Trump
today I am convinced he is more
determined than ever to increase
stimulus payments to $2,000 per
person and challenge section
to 30 big tax liability
protection both are reasonable
demands do you worry
we're heading for a government
shutdown sir I really don't know
I think the president has not
actually explicitly said
he's going to veto this bill I
take that as a hopeful sign I
think as he leaves office he
will I understand he wants to be
remembered for advocating
for big checks.
But the danger is he'll be
he'll be remembered for chaos
and misery and erratic behavior
if if he allows us to expire
so I think the best thing to do
as I say sign this and then make
the case for subsequent
legislation House Speaker Nancy
Pelosi is going to hold a floor
vote on the $2,000 stimulus item
President Trump has requested
putting all House Republicans
on the record how can
Republicans vote against more
aid when millions of Americans
are still unemployed through no
fault of their own Yeah
because it's terribly targeted
right why would we be sending
$2,000 to people with a six
figure income who've had no
suspension no reduction
of their income at
all consider the millions
of federal employees never
missed the check they're not
going to miss a check
their expenses are probably
somewhat diminished savings rate
went through the roof why would
we be sending several thousand
dollars to to these folks this
money isn't sitting on a shelf
we're going to print it
or we're going to borrow it.
And I think that the aid should
be much much more targeted it
should be targeted to people who
have actually lost their job
small businesses that are
actually in danger of going
under those are very real
categories the numbers are
significant that's where the aid
should go not to people
who've never had any loss
of income President Trump
pardoned some former campaign
aides former GOP Congressman his
son-in-law, Jared Kushner his
father, former Blackboard
security operatives
your colleague, Senator Ben
Sasse saying, quote, This is
rotten to the core,
while the president certainly
has the power do you disagree
with how he's using it in some
cases I do I think the case
of Mike Flynn for instance was
completely legitimate to pardon
him because the prosecution was
a abuse of power.
I don't think Michael Flynn ever
committed a crime but some
of these other cases I mean,
my goodness we have tax fraud
and bank fraud witness tampering
obstruction of justice
but because they were close
to the president they got
pardoned this is unfortunately
reminiscent of the Marc rich
pardon by President Clinton it
is legal, it is constitutional
but I think it's a misuse
of the power some are suggesting
it is time to reform
presidential pardon powers do
you agree you know it's a good
discussion to have.
But it's it's a tough call this
is obviously a constitutional
power.
So I don't know how we would do
it without amending
the Constitution.
And I think that I think it
would be very challenging do you
anticipate a lot more pardons
before he leaves office Senator
I don't know what to anticipate
this president is often
unpredictable President Trump
continues disputing the outcome
of the 20 2020 presidential
contests do you have concerns
about it hurting Republicans
in Georgia where those critical
runoffs will decide the Senate
Majority well I think
the president should accept
the outcome of the election he
had every right to challenge
these votes in he had every
right to recount and to litigate
he has done all of those things
in my state of Pennsylvania.
He's drawn conservative
Republican judges who dismiss
these cases for a lack of any
credible evidence in the case
of Georgia I think the reason
we're going to win is we have
better candidates I think
that's just an objective fact,
better candidates and people who
better reflect the wishes
of the people of Georgia
and Kelly loffler and David
Perdue two terrific senators
so I'm I'm still cautiously
optimistic about Georgia what
are the stakes there in Georgia
in terms of what's the big
difference between a Senate led
by majority Leader Mitch
McConnell or perhaps a majority
Leader Chuck Schumer well
the difference is if Republicans
hold the Senate then legislation
will necessarily reflect broad
compromise because both parties
will have some say and neither
party will be able to simply run
off at will if Republicans were
to lose both Senate races
in Georgia then the Democrats
will have complete control
of the elected government
and I'm afraid
that much of that party has been
taken over by this radical woak
left and a very liberal agenda
openly advocating socialism
calling themselves socialists
advocating for the elimination
of police departments I mean
just all kinds of crazy policies
and there will be no check
on those policies except
whatever they choose to however
they choose to limit themselves
and that's not very reassuring.
So I think for the sake of some
balance and some consensus
government.
It's really important that
Republicans hold
on to the Senate back to the 20
2020 presidential contest front
and center is
the president's fight your state
of Pennsylvania
the president's campaign has
asked the Supreme Court to throw
out three state Supreme Court
rulings on mail in ballots
and asking that General Assembly
be allowed to pick its own slate
of electors even if it
doesn't overturn the entire
election is that argument valid.
So again it gets complicated
the Pennsylvania State Supreme
Court sadly is a rogue court
where Democrats have decided
to be extremely political
and disregard the law
that's a fact and one
of the examples is we have
a statute that says,
in order to be counted ballots
have to arrive
by o'clock on election day
it's black and white it's very
easy to read that's what the law
says and then the Pennsylvania
Supreme Court came along
and said we'll disregard that
and allow votes to be counted
for up to three days after that
they have no legal authority
to do that it's outrageous
but here's the important point
Mike it's fewer than 10,000
votes President Trump lost
Pennsylvania by over 80,000
votes.
So even though that was a very
bad decision I think it should
be overturned by the US Supreme
Court.
It wouldn't have changed
the outcome of the election
and that's something we we have
to recognize you're not running
again in 2022 but what are
your concerns looking forward
about elections in your home
state when at least
the president's supporters think
this election was a disaster
well I think there are some
lessons we should learn there
are some changes we should make
we should overturn these
completely illegal Pennsylvania
State Supreme Court rules I
for one think it's perfectly OK
for us to go back to the rules
we had before the pandemic where
the vast majority of people
voted in person that served us
for I don't over 200 years are
probably still works if you
really can't make it
to the polls on election day you
can get an absentee ballot but I
think that would make all
the sense in the world to go
back to that system it's easier
to monitor it's easy to verify
and people would have more
confidence that President Trump
waited until the final hour
on Wednesday to veto
the National Defense
Authorization Act,
which you voted in favor
of the defense bill affirms 3%
pay raises for US troops
and authorizes more than $740
billion in military programs
and construction do you have
the votes to override President
Trump's veto well I think
we'll find out pretty soon this
legislation has been passed
by Congress every year for I
think about 60 years running
it's been signed by presidents I
think it does put the right
priorities behind our defense
policy and it passed both houses
with huge overwhelming votes
but we'll see that's that's why
you have the vote Senator Toomey
thank you.
Thanks for joining us this
Christmas holiday weekend
I'll see you back.